Vaeman reacts to WICK TV being way too
liberal with the way he eats while on
stream.
>> [laughter]
>> Like I'm eating. He's like he's he's
actually dude, what's going on?
>> I'm eating some ramen.
This is what you're doing with your
content and your time on your channel?
You are watching me eat. This is a this
is a perfect clip of [laughter] eating.
So, we're in the midst of a response
from liberal streamer NATO right now. I
don't know if you know about this, have
you heard about this? Liberal streamer
NATO. I don't know if you saw this the
other day, but WICK posted this. Just so
I'm clear, one of my goals I'll be
trying to accomplish is to start
building bridges between liberal and
center leftish creators. We've been too
isolated for too long. The swarm of far
leftists constantly isolate, harass, and
attack us anytime we're critical of
them.
It makes people scared to speak up or
speak out. So, let's build bridges,
build connections. I want to start a
liberal streamer NATO. We're in the
brainstorming stages here, but that is
my goal. Stay safe out there, friends.
Destiny, please protect me please
protect me on the internet, Destiny.
Please protect me on the internet,
Destiny. [laughter] Please stop them
making fun making fun of the way I eat.
It's just like so obviously what's
happening here, right? It's just like
that is obviously the point of this
tweet. Now, WICK has responded to a
heinous attack I've launched on him,
okay? He's invoking the article 50, I
don't remember, man. Article 50 of
liberal streamer NATO. So, let's take a
look. What was this heinous attack? Why
did it occur? What was going on? Let's
take a look. Article five, sorry. I
added a zero, like
Yeah, so this is on the 17th of this
month. Yeah, this is from five days ago.
And let's just see let's see what I
said. Let's see what could have upset
WICK so much. I
against working with people like Tucker,
people like Marjorie Taylor Greene, but
on
>> It really depends, but yeah, go ahead.
>> context, right? I guess
>> Yeah. in this context, I just don't know
what we get from working with me. I
agree. Hold on.
>> she bring? Well, let me just ask. She's
got one of the lowest approval ratings
across the board of any politician. Uh
she's
Yeah, what does she bring to the table?
She's not particularly adept at policy.
She's not
really smart.
Sorry, so she's stupid. So, what are we
getting out of this?
I agree with all this, and I think I I
made the case for, you know, if if you
want to build an ad or even say like
like even do an ad with her and go even
someone as crazy as Marjorie Taylor
Greene disagrees with her. That's how
far Trump has gone that she's that he's
removing all of the loyalists in his
base. I think that that could be
rhetorically helpful. I don't think MTG
would want to do that ad, but you know,
if you could, you know, uh I think that
that's fine. That's fine rhetoric there
to say that Trump has exercised all of
>> real.
So, let's let's add some analysis here.
So, obviously I think we can identify
from the title and some of the footage
here
roughly where this is going.
>> I made the case for, you know, if if you
want to build an ad So, he grabs he
grabs his pot noodle and puts it inside
there. or even say like like even do an
ad with her and He's inspecting he's
inspecting he's he's really trying to
make sure he gets a full a full forkful
there, like a complete forkful. Just
totally heaping it.
Heaping it. Letting it drain, heaping it
some more. someone as crazy as Marjorie
Taylor Greene disagrees with her. That's
how far Trump has gone that she's
>> Yeah, shut up. And then he's he's All
right, he starts shoving he starts
shoving it into his mouth.
But then some drops, I believe. Did I
just see him place
quite a significant amount of noodle in
the front of his mouth and then release
some of the noodles back into the cup?
an ad or even say like like even do an
ad with her and go even someone as crazy
as Marjorie Taylor Greene disagrees with
her. That's how far Trump has gone that
she's that he's
Yeah, he bites it off and and and drops
it back in. He doesn't even properly,
you know,
um what would you say tangle the noodles
around the fork
so that he can he can eat it. He instead
heaps up a huge amount of noodles
and then using his, I believe, incisors
uh seems to be cutting half of half of
the noodles and allowing them to drop
back into the cup, which is frankly a
disgusting way of eating.
Frankly disgusting way of eating. He's
removing all of the loyalists in his
base. I think that that could be
rhetorically helpful. I don't think MTG
would want to do that ad, but you know,
if you could, you know, uh I think that
that's fine. I think he's pulling faces
while he does it, too. I don't know if
you see it if you put if you're seeing
the faces he's pulling.
But between his little eating sessions
here. Greene disagrees with her. That's
how far Trump has gone that she's that
he's removing all of the loyalists in
his base. I think that could be
rhetorically helpful. I don't think MTG
would want to do that ad.
>> So, you've still got a little bit of
noodle on the side of his side of his
lip there. He's brushing it off onto the
floor. He's removing all of the
loyalists in his base. I think that that
could be rhetorically helpful. I don't
think MTG would want to do that ad, but
you know, if you could, you know, uh I
think that that's fine. He's like I say,
he's pulling these faces, man. He's
pulling these [__] faces.
>> that ad, but you know, if you could, you
know, uh I think that that's fine.
That's fine rhetoric there to say that
Trump has exercised all of his base
>> Are you guys back for the same technique
again? So, that is just how he eats
noodles, I guess. loyalists have
realized who he is. And now, guys, he is
talking with his mouth full.
Guys, he has not finished
eating that portion of noodles he just
grabbed with the fork. And he's already
began opening his mouth to talk to the
[snorts] people on the panel.
He just had to get his point out that
desperately. you know, uh I think that
all of the loyalists in his base I think
that that could be rhetorically helpful.
I don't think MTG would want to do that
ad, but you know, if you could, you
know, uh I think that that's fine.
That's fine rhetoric there to say that
Trump has exercised all of his base so
much so that even his loyalists have
realized who he is. Re- remember, like
Ro Khanna didn't just say this.
And that's why I'm against Ro Khanna.
I'm against
>> the tweet. Like Ro Khanna so much so
WICK stuffing his face on camera then
eating with his mouth full. Look at his
face here, man.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, his face Look at his food, bro.
Look at how happy he is.
So, this is now past me, guys, to be
totally clear. Let's just I'm going to
let past me play uninterrupted so you
don't get confused. that even his
loyalists have realized who he is. Re-
remember, like Ro Khanna didn't just say
this.
And that's why I'm against Ro Khanna.
>> I'm against the tweet.
>> Like Ro Khanna so much so WICK stuffing
his face on camera then eating with his
mouth full. Look at his face here, man.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, his face Look at his food, bro.
Look at how happy he is.
Look at how [__] [laughter] happy he
looks. Look at how happy
>> [laughter]
>> Look at how I zoom. Can I zoom? Look at
that. Look at that, man.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude.
That's fine rhetoric there to say that
Trump has exercised all of his base so
much so
>> Pot noodle, dude. He's He's having
[__] pot noodle.
>> Re- remember, like Ro Khanna didn't just
say this.
>> [laughter]
>> And that's why I'm against Ro Khanna.
>> I'm against the tweet.
>> Yeah, he went on a podcast with her and
they had like this uh I don't know if it
was an hour or two-hour long podcast
session where they basically were like
>> So, so that's Guys, that is the clip.
Okay, let's let's now see a little bit
more of him eating. I think we've got
some more
eating here to go through.
That is not a coalition at all. That is
a that is a It's not enough to build a
party on. Yeah, that's like okay, well,
you're you you think bad things that I
think are bad are bad. Like okay, cool.
Let's ignore the fact that you want to
do the great replacement theory
rhetoric, right? Like you can't you
can't base that like that's like saying
you can't He most yeah, participated in
January 6th, the overthrowing of the
government. That to me is a pretty big
non-starter. That's a [__] no-go for
me. Um that I have a real problem with,
and also that I don't have a problem
necessarily that she would that he was
on a podcast with
>> Yeah, sorry sorry. I looked away for a
moment there. I think I'm better.
I missed I missed another session.
I hear that.
is saying that we need an anti-Epstein
class anti-war pro-working class
coalition. That is not a coalition at
all. That is a that is a There is no
party on. Yeah, that's like okay, well,
you're you you think bad things that I
think are bad are bad. Like okay,
the fact that you want to
do the great replacement theory
rhetoric, right? Like you can't you
can't base that like that's like saying
you can't
He's He's digging in there. He's digging
in. government. That to me is a pretty
big non-starter. That's a [__] no-go
for me. Um that I have a real problem
with, and also that I don't have a
problem necessarily that she would that
he was on a podcast with Marjorie Taylor
Greene for 2 hours, but I do have a
problem Even the warmonger from the
2000s that you guys hate can see that
Trump is a threat. That should be enough
for you to vote against him. Trying to
appeal to Republicans, not hey, here we
are together like, you know, I hear
that. Like there's there's ways you
present this, and I think like that is
also the
>> he's pulling, right? Well, I actually
don't know what the polling was, but I I
know a lot of people who were alienated
by that, who grew up during the Bush
years, who grew up and said, "Hey, Dick
Cheney is an evil, you know, mass
murderer." And then you're here being
buddy-buddy with him. That made them
apathetic to vote for Kamala. So, you
have to be very careful about the
rhetoric surrounding this. That doesn't
mean you can't accept the help. That
doesn't mean you can't do something
together. It means you cannot treat this
like it's just any other, you know,
>> I'm getting a sense that this is going
to be a lot of soy pill in this country,
but we don't care about the politics,
[__] Lula can't say I think that's
it. I think that's all the eating we
got.
Wait, yeah.
No, he's probably Look, he's still again
again, he's looking down at it like it's
his [__] child, dude.
>> only would
>> purge demons just to give everyone
universal health care. Would you accept
the health
>> This is like this is like how, you know,
he would look at his newborn if he, you
know,
didn't waste his life.
And so he would look at his like newborn
child.
You know, this is the same face, the
same the same look of like satisfaction,
you know, pride.
The answer is probably yeah, but you
just have to be
very obviously telling everyone
>> be I would be terrified of the next
thing he was going to do. We could
weaponize his insanity, right?
You know. Well, no, I'm just I'm just
real I'm just real curious. Would
everyone accept I don't know if I would,
right? Cuz I There's some im- He's
getting a sick thrill of feed account.
Um, the fact that Liz Cheney
Because
Because [clears throat]
uh
I don't know, like the fact that Liz
Cheney is standing by you, like it's
like, "Hey, we're both in favor of
supporting Ukraine during the in in the
in the Russia-Ukraine war." Um, I think
that that almost signals to a lot of
voters that we should that they should
be more skeptical of the Look at him
eating. He's absolutely [__] going
for the noodles. behind for in
policy-wise kind of a bunch of cluster
[__] Um, so I do [clears throat] think
that aligning yourself with the enemy
and I said the enemy in quotes, I guess,
but like not really not really in
quotes. Um, putting yourself like
aligning yourself with them kind of
shows Well, they're not the enemy. It's
still us. That's the had the same
intention. Um
I I think we get we get the point here.
I don't know if we're going to get much
more.
No, he's he's still going. He's still
going. shooting was a false flag. Could
I throw out an idea?
I And this is mostly coming from
something that happened today.
>> I I think he's got to be pretty much
done now, right? He's got to be done
with them noodles. Yeah, I reckon he's
done I reckon he's finished his noodles.
All right, well, that that solves that.
That solves that.
Now,
why are we talking about this again,
guys?
Why would we be possibly following up
on the story of Wick
eating on camera?
What reason could there possibly be
cringe for us to follow up on this?
Well, let's take a look at his stream
from a day ago, guys. There's also look,
none of us are perfect.
None of us are perfect.
And Very true. Very true. No No one's
perfect. What's Wick's example?
>> I I was watching this,
I recognized there are certain behaviors
that I engage in
that this video is calling out. And I
have to change. I have to repent. It's
In many ways it's like a call to
repentance, I guess, for influencers in
general. And it's just true. There are
ways I have behaved online
that are
unacceptable, and I need to change. I
need to stop doing this.
But the problem is, and it's not an
excuse, to be clear. I'm still guilty.
But the problem is is everything about
this space incentivizes
horrific behavior, treating other people
in horrific ways, never being genuine,
>> [snorts]
>> never being vulnerable. It will be used
against you. I'll give you an example.
Dude.
It's crazy.
The the priming, the leading the segue
here is insane. Let's roll it back.
Let's just hear what he's saying here.
But the problem is, in [laughter] many
ways it's like a call to repentance, I
guess, for influencers in general. And
it's just true. There are ways I have
behaved online
that are Wait a minute, guys. In this
context, what's Lauren Southern talking
about here? What did she do in like her
younger years
that she might regret?
Well, she was named in like the the
Christchurch shooting manifesto of like
50 Muslims got gunned down in New
Zealand.
So, that's one thing she might be
thinking about repenting for.
Um
What's Wick's example of [laughter]
something the content creator is about
what to repent for? Some some horrific
behavior they engage in. In many ways
it's like a call to repentance, I guess,
for influencers in general. And it's
just true. There are ways I have behaved
online
They tried to try to stop a boat from
saving drowning migrants. There's that
one. unacceptable, and I need to change.
I need to stop doing this.
But the problem is, and it's not an
excuse, to be clear. I'm still guilty.
But the problem is is everything about
this space incentivizes
horrific behavior, treating other people
in horrific ways, never being genuine,
never being vulnerable. It will be used
against you. I'll give you an example.
I'll give you an example, a simple one.
Excuse me. Coughing answers have it all.
>> is uh
this is this is someone tweeting about
me,
right? From last week.
Right? Queenman reacts to Wick TV being
way too liberal with the way he eats
while on stream.
>> [laughter]
>> It's so good, man. It's so [__] good.
>> It's horrific behavior. It's horrific
behavior. [laughter]
Here's a simple example.
Someone tweeted at me,
"Wick being way too liberal with
[laughter] the way he eats on stream."
>> [snorts]
>> It's so [__] [laughter] good, man.
His eyes
His eyes are going two separate ways.
Dude, WHAT'S
HOLY [laughter] [__]
>> [laughter]
>> DUDE, WHAT'S
OH MY GOD.
Oh my god, dude.
>> [snorts]
[laughter]
>> Holy [__]
Okay.
Let's pull up the substance tweet.
Let's [laughter] pull up the substance
tweet quickly.
And just play the clip cuz he doesn't
play the audio.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh I think that that's fine. That's fine
rhetoric there to say that Trump has
excised all of his base so much so that
even his loyalists have realized who he
is. Dude. so much so Wick stuffing his
face on camera then eating with his
mouth full. Look at his face here, man.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, his face looks like a food
profile.
Look how [laughter] [__] happy he
looks. Look at that.
Look at that.
Look at that, man.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude.
fine. That's fine rhetoric there to say
that It's [__] dude.
He's having [__] hot noodle.
So,
>> [laughter]
>> it's like it's a very mild clip. I'm
going to be real. Queenman reacts to
Wick TV being way too liberal with the
way he eats while on stream.
Dude, his eyes are going two
Holy hell, he's actually like a full
30 seconds like not 30 seconds, like a
full few seconds. He's actually just His
eyes are like this.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude.
That's just completely insane.
Bros, I'm just eating here.
Like I'm eating. He's like His eyes
actually Dude, what's going on? I'm
eating some ramen.
It was yummy ramen.
It's a very simple thing.
But you got like what? How many people?
Like 53 likes on this? Over almost 2,000
views Dude, this is like the craziest
part as well. It's a 50 like tweet.
That's not a big tweet, dude. That's not
a popular tweet.
Do you know what Do you know what tweet
has way more likes
than that tweet?
Almost double the likes that tweet had.
Like this is uh this is this is someone
tweeting about me,
right? From last week.
Right? Queenman reacts to Wick TV being
way too liberal with the way he eats
while on stream. Bros, I'm just eating
here.
Like I'm eating.
I'm eating some ramen. It was yummy
ramen.
It's
>> [laughter]
>> dude.
It's so crazy. He's just like so
[__] Why would you Why would you
see the malice on stream and say it's
like this horrific thing that happened
to you?
It's just so funny. It's so funny, man.
some ramen.
It was yummy ramen.
It's a very simple thing.
But you got like what? How many people?
Like 53 likes on this? Over almost 2,000
views of people just watching
some I don't know, some weirdo watch me
eat. And can I just take a moment in in
He's like, "Dude, I was watching the
panel. I was there to watch the panel.
You were eating on camera, okay? The
whole point is people don't want to
watch you eat, Wick. That's the whole
joke.
Is that it's gross?
It's just so crazy, man. It's so crazy.
I was like, "Dude, I'm there to watch
the panel.
You were eating on camera. I am watching
you eat."
Because you decided in the middle of a
panel to start slurping up cup ramen
in a in a bizarre way
and talking with your mouth full.
That's why this clip exists, Wick.
How
po-
How meaningless, how purposeful
purposeless does your life have to be
here?
This is what you're doing with your
content and your time on your channel.
You are watching me eat. You're
Thank you for watching my content.
Thanks for being a fan.
I mean, he's a fan. But this is this is
what you're doing with your time. This
is what you
>> Long ti- long time fan, as I will prove
in a moment. Like
anything you do as a content creator
online,
anything you say as a content creator
is you're online. You're on a stage,
and people are watching you. And they
will clip you and they will take you and
they will
>> And so you have to see performers eating
on stage. Is that like a common thing,
like
edit you and they will do all these
things with you. They'll take any moment
in time of yours and they'll try to
portray it in the worst light possible
because for them it's it's either A,
it's funny for them or B, they hate you
and they want to punish you and all
these things.
So, I learned very early on
never ever ever be genuine
and vulnerable. Not at the same time. I
try my hardest to be genuine
but vulnerable, almost never. I will
almost never do that. You get punished
for it. Never be vulnerable online and
it sucks that you can't do that.
And it's one of the reasons why I again
and she'll say this later
>> Yeah, there are much worse lights you
can paint Wick in. Trust me.
I'm about to do it. deal.
Um, and I agree with her. I don't think
you can be Christian online.
Part of being Christian
in a real sense is being vulnerable.
Is opening is
is
like
admitting
that you
This is over a clip of him eating, guys.
I feel like you need to be reminded of
this.
This is a this is over a clip of him
eating. that you
aren't enough. Right? That's the whole
purpose. You're not enough. That's the
whole theology behind Christianity. That
you are not enough. That's what he's
saying, guys. He's
stuffing [laughter] his face with cup
noodle on stream. That's what he's
coming to you hat in hand saying, "I'm
not enough. I'm not enough."
And you need the intercession
of Christ to make you enough. You need
to rely [laughter] on him. You need to
rely on him. And
you cannot make it there on your own.
You'll fall short.
So, you have to rely on Christ to get
you there.
And so, to do that you have to be
vulnerable.
You have to and it talks about it in the
scripture all the time warning again and
again and again and again of pride.
Warning against pride, right?
Hard-heartedness, stiff-neckedness,
okay?
All these things
that
being humble, being vulnerable
>> Great great rant. [laughter]
can help you correct.
>> cup noodle But, yeah, online, never do
that. It's a it's a mistake.
You will be punished for it. And this is
just a silly thing, right?
It's not a big deal, but it's a good
example. [laughter]
Any moment of joy you have on stream,
too. Like there's there's clips Like
when you're enjoying your cup noodle.
>> [laughter]
>> It's a silly thing, right? [snorts]
It's not a big deal, but it's a good
example.
Any moment of joy you have on stream,
too. Like there's [laughter] there's
clips that they'll post of me
to make fun of me because I'm dancing on
stream.
And it's because we had like a dance off
on on screen or something or like it was
the during the Riz off that I had. It
was a fun little event, okay? It's fun.
Everyone What's he referencing that,
guys? What's he referencing that? Well,
we've got that one. We've got that one.
This is a classic, yeah. Newer viewers
might not have seen. Oh, that's fine.
What whatever whatever Here's one for
you, okay?
Let me
You know I literally, by the way, I did
not even I didn't prep this.
I just thought of it. So, it's Wick TV
Pixie Race Royale. And this video is
automatically timestamped to the exact
right moment on my on my browser even
though I haven't pulled this up in about
6 months. Get the all
you know, the exercises getting you a
moment a moment. You know
you know you got to work up to it,
right? You can't just go in, right? You
got to like give it some time. So, let
me let me moisturize my throat here.
Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> You don't always have to [__] her hard.
In fact, sometimes that's not right to
do.
Sometimes you got to make some love
and [__] give her some smooches, too.
Sometimes you got to squeeze.
Sometimes you got to say, "Please."
Sometimes you got to say, "Hey,
I'm going to [__] you
gently.
I'm going to screw [singing]
you sweetly. I'm going to hug you
>> [laughter]
>> What's the next one? You got it? There
you go.
She's got the gist.
Didn't even need See, I don't need that
much time to satisfy a woman. Just that
way.
enjoying it. But, they'll clip you and
try to use those moments of joy against
you because honestly, they're miserable
people, right? They're fun suckers,
okay?
But, it's it's just everywhere online.
Constantly. All the time.
These people are just
I don't know. They're they're sad. And I
feel real bad for them.
Like any Look, anyone who
if you're having to watch me on stream
to try to make fun of me
>> for you.
Bro,
you've fallen pretty far.
You've fallen pretty far.
>> What do you mean, Wick? This is how I
got my start. I got to say.
He's signaling explains a lot. Why
you'll see tons of political accounts
use Okay, so that's the full clip.
That's the full clip. So, we have got
just a last couple of Wick clips to
round off this segment, guys.
Okay.
Anyways, next question.
Is
Is blackface or brownface ever okay?
Only if you're a pretty kitty.
Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> So good, man. There we go. That
>> I think that's the Wick segment, guys.